to assemble the pump a worker begins
with the first part of the two part body
the worker applies glue to the shaft
sleeve and inserts it into a channel
from the front next they insert a
Lantern ring into the same channel from
the back the worker places a bearing on
top of the Lantern ring then from the
other side
they insert one more bearing the worker
inserts the pump shaft through all the
bearings in the channel the bearings
minimize friction enabling the shaft to
rotate smoothly along with this
retaining clip the bearings also prevent
the shaft from moving up and down or
shifting side by side with the pumps
movement workers take the second part of
the pumps body and glue a bronze plate
called a diaphragm into a groove at the
top then they join the two parts of the
body placing a gasket in between to
prevent leaks the gasket is made of
special gasket paper like the type used
in car engine Piper the workers fasten
the two parts of the body with ten
massive bolts and install a heavy-duty
steel spring and a groove in the shaft a
steel cap keeps the spring firmly in
position
the worker compresses the spring with a
tool and inserts a bran stem bushing
this spring loading is critical because
it enables the disc to adapt to thin or
thick liquids without clogging or
getting damaged
now they mount the hollow disc onto the
bushing and bolt on the front cover when
the motor turns the pump shaft the
hollow disc oscillates around the
diaphragm which acts as a barrier
separating the suction side of the pump
from the discharge side this plate
covers where the customer will later
install a safety valve the oscillating
holo-disk produces suction which pulls
liquid through the inlet port then out
the opposite side through the outlet
port the disc can also rotate in Reverse
so that liquid can be loaded or unloaded
using the same pump